♪
>> Tucker: WELL, IF YOU WATCHED
THE SHOW OVER THE LAST YEAR YOU
HAVE SEEN US CELEBRATE CHRIS
CUOMO.
WHAT BEGANS GENTLE MOCKING
BECAME ADMIRATION AND THEN LOVE
AS WE WATCHED HIM GIVE PROFOUND
AND HAUNTING INSIGHTS IN THE
HUMAN CONDITION.
WE WROTE HIM OFF AS A SEMI-
ILLITERATE BUFFOON.
HE IS AN ARTIST AND THE SEAR AND
LEADING HIS PEOPLE FROM THE
SCREECHING CHAOS OF THIS WORLD
TO THE BLISSFUL CLARITY OF THE
NEXT.
HE IS A SHAM AN AND HE ARE HIS
ACCOLADES.
AND NOW HE IS CLAIMING TO BE
SOMETHING ELSE ENTIRELY.
IN A RECENT INTERVIEW WITH THE
HOLLYWOOD REPORTER.
HE'S NOT THE EASTERN MISTER AND
WE WARN YOU IT IS A SHOCK BUT
MERELY A JOURNALIST AND A FACT
MAN AND SHOE LEATHER REPORTER
AND DOESN'T LET HIS OPINION GET
IN THE WAY OF THE NEWS, THAT'S
WHY I CAME TO CNN.
IMAGINE OUR BEWILDERMENT.
JUST A JOURNALIST.
IS IT TRUE OR A VEIL MEANT TO
CONFUSE THE BUILDINGERS.
HERE'S THE CHRIS CUOMO WE KNOW.
>> THAT'S THE JOB AND SENSE OF
DUTY.
ACT WITH YOUR HEAD AND NOT JUST
YOUR HEART.
IF IS A TURBER GET UP AND
SURFACE GET UP.
THERE YOU GO, BRO.
EXCELLENT.
MAKE IT EASY AND KEEP IT TIGHT.
HOLD ON.
HASH TAG, PLEASE USE IT.
>> Tucker: JUST A JOURNALIST